[Musique]
bonjour
wen en dix mois tony arrêté
ouais vous êtes avec son pote tony c'est
bien ça que ça a donné
alex alex harvey
c'est quoi ces primes j'ai quelqu'un aux
flatulences en fait j'ai mangé un
mauvais tacos à munich mais vous pouvez
maintenant vous avez les flatulences je
suis une cliente comment c'est possible
ça pas le bon bout de ses peines
[Musique]
j'ai aujourd'hui pas loin mais dire je
tenais à vous prévenir
je sens que ça va voir si ça c'est pas
con parce que
[Musique]
je voulais contre
vous savez savary retenir un peu en fait
ça me dérange pas moi de péter en fait
non mais là c'est la provocation que je
crois pas en fait
et si je me suis je n'avais pas les
ballasts arrêté c'est dégueu mais c'est
pas facile
vraiment pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il m'arrive de mise pour ça car c'est ça
suspense et n'ont voulu éviter comme ça
me dérange a demandé si on peut dire
d'être des toilettes voulait descendre
pour demander s'ils voyagent tous de
péter en même temps on améliorait la la
couche d'ozone
commençait alors que je fume pas je vais
pas supporter
[Rires]
[ __ ] de merde
arrêté le foot mais c'est du troc une
adresse bajaur mais je ne sais je
voudrais pris la journée là bas non
merci je sais mais chez moi c'est parce
que là j'ai pas trop de vous les verrez
moi c'est mieux c'est quand même vous
prenez pour qui à madame soleil c'est
tellement je suis benjamin castaldi
c'est vrai quoi ressemble comme ça lui
ressemble pas terrible au monde que je
connais c'est cyril hanouna web ainsi
que la ceni sur l'agora sera ouais vous
êtes dedans je me suis fait mieux en
fait